hace ya algo más de 10 años todos vimos
con estupor estás sobreactuadas imágenes
el 17 de diciembre del 2011 falleció de
un infarto cardíaco el dictador coreano
kim jong-il tras dirigir con puño de
hierro el país durante 17 años entre el
94 y el 2021 durante su reinado cora del
norte vivió la peor hambruna de su
historia la conocida como la ardua
marcha que dejó según las diferentes
estimaciones entre medio millón y tres
millones y medio de muertos por
inanición
tras la muerte de kim jong-il heredó el
poder su hijo kim jong-un un liderará
mundialmente conocido pero cuyo perfil
en aquella época a duras penas se
conocía tanto dentro como fuera de corea
del norte la transición que duró desde
diciembre del año 2011 hasta el mes de
abril del 2012 terminó con un joven de
apenas 29 años asumiendo el control
total sobre el partido del trabajo de
corea y también del ejército como los de
su padre los poderes de kim jong-un
pasaron a ser absolutos
pues bien este entonces ha pasado ya más
de una década una década durante la cual
el reino ermitaño de ideologías uche ha
estado bajo el control total de kim
jong-un no ha dejado de copar
regularmente los titulares de los
principales medios internacionales estoy
seguro de que la mayoría de vosotros
conocéis ya algunos de los grandes
acontecimientos que han rodeado a este
hermético país durante estos diez años
destacando sin lugar a dudas su
conversión en toda una potencia nuclear
ahora bien realmente cómo ha cambiado
corea del norte durante este tiempo cómo
ha logrado el joven kim consolidar su
liderazgo en un régimen dominado por
viejas glorias que se esconde tras las
principales decisiones adoptadas por el
gran líder y quizás la pregunta más
importante de todas hacia dónde se
dirige corea del norte pues bien estas y
más preguntas os las vamos a contestar
en este vídeo así que arranquemos ya
[Aplausos]
es una pregunta sabías que cada año las
empresas se gastan más de un billón de
dólares en recomprar sus propias
acciones en los últimos años esta se ha
convertido en una de las prácticas más
habituales de wall street y el resto de
mercados financieros las empresas se
gastan cantidades desorbitadas de dinero
en adulterar la demanda de sus propias
acciones esto ha hecho que por ejemplo
la administración baiden le haya pedido
al congreso que castigue estas
operaciones ahora bien en qué consiste
esta práctica porque se ha puesto tan de
moda que problemas y qué ventajas
conlleva para conocer una de las grandes
tendencias de wall street no te pierdas
el último vídeo de si lo hubiera sabido
el canal de información financiera de
mutuactivos con el que participamos os
dejamos el enlace abajo en la
descripción dicho esto continuemos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
queridos amigos amigas podemos dividir
la década que kim jong-un ha estado al
frente de corea del norte en cuatro
grandes etapas la primera entre 2012 y
2013 fue la fase de consolidación de su
poder la segunda entre 2013 y 2017 la
podríamos denominar como la fase de
onsen luego hablaremos más de ello la
tercera entre el 18 y el 19 fue la fase
de la diplomacia y la cuarta desde el
2019 hasta nuestros días y en la
podríamos conocer como la fase cobit
pues bien las dos primeras fases
supusieron un impulso un cambio clave en
la política norcoreana el fin de la
conocida como doctrina son woods
según fue la doctrina norcoreana kim
pero en todas las políticas del dictador
kim jong-il esta doctrina se basaba en
la idea del ejército primero y conforme
a ella las fuerzas armadas norcoreanas
eran siempre prioritarias es decir el
uso de los recursos disponibles debía
dirigirse siempre en primer lugar al
desarrollo de las capacidades militares
del país el resultado fue el impulso
definitivo del programa nuclear y
balístico en 2013 sin embargo kim
jong-un decidió que esta política tenía
que flexibilizarse y que a partir de ese
momento el desarrollo del ejército
tendría que ir siempre acompañado del
desarrollo civil y así fue como nació la
doctrina avión sino que literalmente
significa desarrollo paralelo conforme a
esta nueva política los recursos del
país ya no sólo se destinarían a las
fuerzas armadas sino también a mejorar
las condiciones de vida de los
norcoreanos al menos de los más fieles
al régimen
[Música]
ahora bien porque quien decidió llevar a
cabo un cambio tan importante apenas un
año después de hacerse con el poder
total y absoluto pues básicamente lo
hizo porque la economía estaba
destrozada tras el mandato de kim
jong-il tras la terrible hambruna el
esfuerzo realizado en desarrollar armas
de destrucción masiva en declive de sus
viejas e ineficientes industrias el país
ya no daba más de sí así que el actual
líder apostó por este cambio con el
objetivo de que la mejora en las
condiciones generales de vida y ayudarán
a consolidar su poder y la pregunta es
funciona pues lo cierto es que sí aunque
no por mucho tiempo atentos
[Música]
los felices años del nuevo king
cuando kim jong-un llegó al poder su
juventud y su inexperiencia en los
círculos de poder norcoreanos le
hicieron temer que se produjera un golpe
interno para arrebatarle el mando y
desde luego esa era una posibilidad que
muchos analistas plantearon seriamente
al fin y al cabo kim era un joven que
estuvieron suiza y era todo un fan de la
nba el riesgo ahí estaba este golpe
podría venir de dos frentes del ejército
por parte de algunas de las viejas
glorias más tradicionalistas del régimen
o del partido de la mano de algún líder
que quisiera reformar el sistema tal y
como en cierto modo sucedió en china con
den xiaoping pues bien usa una pregunta
que suelen hacer los dictadores cuando
se toman muy en serio la posibilidad de
que se produzca un golpe de estado para
echarlos del poder
321 exacto implantar un régimen del
terror actuar con rapidez y llevar a
cabo un montón de purgas lo antes
posible vamos de primero de tirano pues
sabéis que eso es exactamente lo que
hizo el líder norcoreano el joven
dictador quiso demostrar que no por ser
joven era débil y desde luego si algo ha
quedado claro con el paso de los años es
que al tipo no tiembla la mano seguro
que todos recordáis el asesinato de su
propio hermano kim jong nam en febrero
del 2017 en el aeropuerto de kuala
lumpur cuando dos mujeres se le
acercaron por detrás y le envenenaron
[Música]
anteriormente a finales del 2013 kim
jong un orden una ejecución mucho más
importante a efectos políticos la de su
tío samson tec un alto cargo del régimen
que fue fusilado tras ser acusado de
faccionalismo o corrupción drogas y
juegos esta fue una de las purgas de más
alto nivel desde los años 50 y la
pregunta es y por qué lo mató pues lo
cierto es que se sospecha que este alto
cargo era contraria a las nuevas
políticas que querían plantar kim
jong-un
[Música]
además en este caso el joven dictador se
encargó de que absolutamente todo el
país y todo el mundo se enterase de este
cambio de juego fue algo así como un
aviso a navegantes de bill quien dice
que soy débil mira por tu bien no te la
juegues llevándome la contraria o tú
serás el siguiente kim jong-un de corea
del norte purga su tío de forma
espectacularmente pública y el caso es
que este tipo de pulgas tuvieron su
efecto desde entonces el liderazgo de
kim no se volvía a poner en cuestión al
menos que se sepa y gracias a eso pudo
implantar la nueva política que el nuevo
líder quería convertir en su máximo
estandarte la doctrina jonsin
bajo la nueva política avión chino de
desarrollo paralelo kim le prometió a su
pueblo que nunca más tendrían que
apretarse el cinturón con este nuevo
modelo quien quería impulsar una reforma
económica al estilo chino es decir sin
apertura política por ejemplo reconoció
los mercados privados y promulgó una ley
que le daba más autonomía a las empresas
públicas la idea era favorecer un cierto
grado de emprendimiento de eficiencia
productiva y competencias y en propiedad
privada y eso no es todo también creó
alrededor de 20 zonas de desarrollo
económico y una ley de joint ventures
con la que intentar atraer capital
extranjero sobre todo capital chino
[Aplausos]
por supuesto hablamos de un país donde
la planificación estatal es
prácticamente omnipresente así que estas
zonas económicas especiales se
dividieron en tres zonas económicas
zonas agrícolas industriales o
turísticas entre otras especialidades
ahora bien la pregunta que podemos
hacernos es sirvieron realmente todas
estas reformas para mejorar la situación
económica del país
[Música]
pues lo cierto es que parece que si las
primeras reformas bajo el liderazgo de
kim jong-un mejoraron las condiciones
económicas del país e incluso se estima
en 2016 su economía tuvo el mejor año
desde
1989 justo antes del colapso de la unión
soviética tampoco es que fuera app para
lanzar cohetes no hablamos de un
crecimiento económico estimado de
aproximadamente el 39 % según cálculos
del banco central de corea del sur
cálculos que se realizan a partir de
informes de inteligencia análisis
satelitales y la evolución de las
exportaciones y las importaciones entre
otros parámetros sea como fuera la
cuestión es que se empezaron a ver más
coches en las calles niveles de consumo
algo mayores en las grandes ciudades y
un cierto auge en el sector de la
construcción he hecho aquí en visual
político tenemos un vídeo en el que os
hablamos de los grandes proyectos de
cora del norte lo dejamos en la
descripción y a ver no se trata de que
el país fuera como un tiro ni mucho
menos pero para los estándares
norcoreanos pues las cosas sí que
empezaron a mejorar y amigos amigas los
cambios no se limitaron al ámbito
económico sólo en el campo político
también hubo novedades fijaos
[Música]
el joven kim reformó la estructura de
poder dentro del estado para que el
ejército ya no fuera la institución más
poderosa del país sino que ésta pasará a
ser el partido es decir bajo el mando de
kim jong-un los cargos civiles se han
impuesto a los militares
eso sí hablamos de cora del norte uno de
los países más militarizados del mundo
así que el líder chucho aprovechó esta
relativa bonanza económica para terminar
de desarrollar el programa de armas
nucleares y balísticas de hecho corea
del norte llevó a cabo dos pruebas
nucleares en 2016 y 2017 incluyendo
supuestamente la bomba de hidrógeno y
también se llevaron a cabo numerosas
pruebas con misiles balísticos
intercontinentales a algunos de los
cuales llegaron incluso a sobrevolar
japón agosto de 2017 misil en tránsito
japón se despierta con una amenazante
advertencia sobre un lanzamiento de
corea del norte las sirenas sonaron los
trenes se detuvieron y los residentes se
pusieron a cubierto cuando un misil
disparado por corea del norte voló sobre
territorio japonés durante dos minutos
obviamente esto ya fueron palabras
mayores misiles norcoreanos sobrevolando
japón y hacemos saltar las armas anti
misiles en uno de los principales
aliados de occidente la respuesta estaba
claro no iba a hacerse esperar
[Música]
y si fueron estas pruebas tanto las
nucleares como las balísticas las que
dieron un portazo al espejismo de
progreso y apertura que parecen haber
puesto en marcha las reformas de kim
jong-un septiembre de 2017 el consejo de
seguridad impone nuevas sanciones a la
república popular democrática de corea
incluida la prohibición de venta de gas
natural y la autorización de trabajo
para sus ciudadanos en ese momento la
comunidad internacional le impuso al
país sanciones más duras que ha sufrido
hasta la fecha incluyendo la prohibición
de venderles gas y severas limitaciones
a las ventas de petróleo además también
se prohibió la concesión de permisos de
trabajo a los norcoreanos de tal forma
que muchas de las empresas públicas que
operaban en el extranjero para conseguir
divisas tuvieron que cerrar lo que por
supuesto acabó con una importante vía de
financiación para el régimen
como os podéis imaginar esto lo cambió
todo la buena racha llegó a su fin y la
economía norcoreana volvió a entrar en
una dura recesión en apenas dos años se
estima que el comercio internacional de
corea del norte se hundió un 57 por
ciento pasando de unos 6.500 millones de
dólares al entorno de los 2.800 y desde
entonces no ha levantado cabeza de esta
forma el plan de kim se fue directamente
a la papelera si había cambiado la
doctrina dominante pero lo que no cambió
fueron las prioridades la supervivencia
del régimen por encima de todo
incluyendo por supuesto las esperanzas
de un mejor nivel de vida de la
población norcoreana ahora bien la
pregunta es qué hizo quin después de
semejante fracaso que se le ocurrió a
este decrépito régimen para salir del
pozo pues presta mucha atención porque
estoy seguro que ahora muchos vais a
entender la historia completa de lo que
pasa con corea del norte
[Aplausos]
[Música]
falsa diplomacia
en 2017 se alinearon los astros para kim
jong-un por un lado estaba a donald
trump como presidente de los eeuu un
líder nada común con un fuerte carácter
populista y encantado de sentarse a
charlar con cualquier tirano incluso con
el líder de la peor dictadura de la
tierra por otro lado acababa de llegar
al poder el ahora ex presidente
surcoreano mountain un discípulo de la
sunshine policy la política de apertura
hacia cora del norte de finales de los
90 que mejor oportunidad para kim
jong-un que aprovechar semejante
panorama y presentarse como un tipo
dispuesto a negociar con una aparente
voluntad de llegar a un acuerdo incluso
aunque esto supusiera la
desnuclearización de corea un viejo
truco norcoreano por cierto pero es que
la cosa iba todavía más allá a fin de
cuentas que el líder democrático no
querría vender un éxito político tan
grande como conseguir un tratado de paz
definitivo para la guerra de korea o la
desnuclearización de la península
coreana el caramelito era muy dulce para
todas las partes
[Música]
el régimen norcoreano se dio cuenta de
que las sanciones de la onu estaban
causando más estragos de lo que habían
calculado así que necesitaban que estas
aliviarán fuera como fuera y la única
forma de conseguirlo era mejorando sus
relaciones con washington lo que pasaba
a sí o sí por detener todas las pruebas
y las constantes provocaciones militares
era el tiempo de la diplomacia de la
diplomacia del farsante
un tipo de diplomacia está consistente
en ofrecer algo que realmente sabían que
no iban a cumplir para lograr lo que el
régimen necesitaba recordáis eso que
dijo kim de que los norcoreanos no
tendrían que volver a apretar el
cinturón pues justamente eso de esta
forma entre los años 2018 y 2019
presenciamos dos imágenes históricas por
un lado un presidente de corea del sur
regresaba a pyongyang después de 11 años
y por otro un dictador norcoreano se
reunía en dos ocasiones mano a mano con
el mismísimo presidente de los eeuu algo
que nunca antes había ocurrido unas
imágenes tan raras como extrañas unas
reuniones que por supuesto no tardaron
mucho en saltar por los aires
el último acercamiento entre corea del
norte eeuu y corea del sur tuvo lugar en
2019 en la ciudad vietnamita de hanoi
esta cumbre fue un auténtico fiasco
después de casi dos años de paripé kim
todavía no había logrado su auténtica
meta que se levantaran las sanciones
contra corea del norte y claro el paripé
sin ningún resultado se estaba ya
alargando tanto que empezaba a dañar al
propio kim el líder norcoreano estaba
mostrando una infrecuente imagen de
debilidad de cara a su propio régimen
digamos que le había dado la mano a su
archienemigo para no conseguir
absolutamente nada
así que bueno digamos que la cumbre de
hanoi terminó prematuramente y según
eeuu estos fueron los motivos
todo iba acerca de las sanciones
básicamente querían que se levantaran
las sanciones en su totalidad y nosotros
no podríamos hacer eso el dilema al que
nos enfrentamos es que los norcoreanos
en este momento no están dispuestos a
congelar por completo sus programas de
armas de destrucción masiva así que dan
alivio de sanciones por valor de muchos
muchos miles de millones de dólares nos
podrían efecto en una posición de
subsidio del desarrollo constante de
armas de destrucción masiva en corea del
norte alto funcionario del departamento
de estado de los eeuu hay que enviar un
kim jong-un que te veo en el farol fue
la pescadilla que se muerde la cola
corea exigía el fin de las sanciones
antes de hacer cualquier gesto y eeuu
exigía que corea del norte desmantelar a
su programa nuclear y balístico antes de
levantar nada era evidente que cualquier
acuerdo era imposible así que todo saltó
por los aires y la crisis económica de
cora del norte continuó hemos llegado ya
hasta el 2019 y esto esto fue lo que
ocurre después atentos
destacada kobe en el país más hermético
del mundo
el 2019 también fue un mal año para el
régimen de kim jong un primero las
sanciones seguían en pie y estaba claro
que no iban a desaparecer así que el
líder norcoreano ya no tenía ningún
incentivo para seguir mostrando una cara
amable para que así que sabéis lo que
hizo pues si regresar a la política de
refuerzo a toda costa de las fuerzas
armadas especialmente en lo que respecta
al armamento estratégico lo hizo quizás
para volver a mostrarse como un tipo
duro y fuerte ante los propios altos
cargos del régimen o quizás para
resarcirse de su fracaso político o
quizás para recordarle al mundo que kim
jong-un no era un tipo ni afable y
bonachón sea como fuere esto supuso el
fin de la doctrina jonsin y el regreso a
las viejas políticas de siempre
siempre estableció en gran medida el
sistema económico de siempre y volvió
hablar en sus discursos de la
importancia de la autosuficiencia lo que
básicamente supone el regreso a la
autarquía dura y estricta que tanto ha
caracterizado a corea del norte y en lo
que respecta a la política exterior kim
jong-un fue progresivamente congelando
todos los diálogos que se habían abierto
en la etapa anterior su máxima expresión
fue volar por los aires la oficina de
enlace intercoreana decae son en junio
del 2020
y por supuesto no olvidéis que a finales
del 2019 comienzos del 2020 fue cuando
se puso en marcha la pandemia del sars
coronavirus 2 una pandemia que como
todos sabéis se originó en china y que
provocó que prácticamente desde el
minuto 1 el régimen volviera a cerrarse
a cal y canto no permitiendo ni siquiera
el comercio con china excepto el de
bienes esenciales así que la economía
norcoreana otra vez volvió a entrar en
recesión y todas las circunstancias en
este país lo que se pierde no se
recupera con la cob y 19 corea del norte
ha vuelto a un estado de aislamiento
prácticamente total a un estado de
autarquía absoluta y de crisis extrema
algo muy parecido o incluso peor a lo
que se encontró kim jong-un cuando
ascendió al trono en 2011
además la falta de infraestructuras
hídricas y las fuertes lluvias han
provocado inundaciones descontroladas en
las épocas del año y sequías extremas en
otras lo que está provocando de nuevo
una crisis alimentaria cuya magnitud
real se desconoce julio del 2022 pueblos
norcoreanos a lo largo de la frontera
con china se han inundado esta semana
tras las fuertes lluvias amenazando con
agravar la ya crítica situación
alimentaria y económica en el país julio
del 2022 la grave escasez de alimentos
en corea del norte podría agudizarse con
el comercio transfronterizo aún
fuertemente restringido por la cob 19 la
ayuda del extranjero será limitada
entonces podríamos hablar de una década
perdida en corea del norte pues no lo
cierto es que no por un lado kim jong-un
ha logrado su objetivo de apuntalar su
poder y dar continuidad a la dinastía
qin lo cual pese a todo no pareció una
tarea sencilla por otra parte los años
de relativa bonanza económica han dejado
importantes desarrollos urbanísticos' en
pyonyang sant sillón o wonsan que han
aportado vivienda nueva a miles de
norcoreanos así como hoteles hospitales
y mejoras en varios aeropuertos entre
otras cosas pero la situación
dado en los últimos dos años podría
incluso poner el liderazgo de kim
jong-un en riesgo y en cualquier caso lo
que parece claro es que el futuro
próximo de cora del norte en pasa por la
falta de cualquier nivel de prosperidad
quien tendrá un largo 2023 para
reflexionar y decidir qué rumbo quiere
para corea del norte en la era post co
beat un regreso a la política de
desarrollo paralelo o una continuación
de la autarquía militarista radical de
la doctrina song world como no puede ser
otra forma aquí en visual político
seguiremos muy pendientes de todos los
acontecimientos que sucedan en el reino
ermitaño pero ahora llegó a este punto
el turno es para ti crees que el ver
algo de kim jong-un está garantizado
hasta que el dictador fallezca qué
camino crees que tomará a corea del
norte en la era post cobit crees que
existe alguna posibilidad de rebelión
interna contra kim por culpa de la
crisis bien de las élites del régimen o
del pueblo pues bien déjanos tus
situaciones aquí abajo en los
comentarios y si te gustó este vídeo no
olvides darle al botón de like y
suscríbete a visual polític donde
también la campanita para no perderte
ninguna novedad y recuerda te gusta lo
que hacemos si quieres ayudarnos a
crecer y mejorar puedes ayudarnos
activamente uniéndote a la comunidad de
visual político en patrón os dejamos el
enlace también abajo en la descripción
un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]